I love their reject nation and I'm metal
beard the pirate none of these several
other characters we watched the lego
movie to the second chapter folks I know
normally when we do our movie reviews
I'm actually sitting over on that red
couch we decided to do a review here for
a variety of reasons that I'm sure
you're just as interested in hearing the
answers to who know we're waiting for
the shaft trailer to drop so kids if
you're watching this review right after
you're done go watch that shaft trailer
reaction - there tends to be a lot of
noise by that window at the hour that we
are shooting so it's better to be here
than over there 3 it's just so much more
comfortable to sit here than it is on
that couch that's a very uncomfortable
couch to do reviews honestly it's a
better set but man it is not as
comfortable the talking experience tell
you you're on the edge you know you're
really focused on your movement you have
more delays before we hop right into our
opinions on this there's a couple of
very specific thank yous we got to give
first off thanks for watching you
beautiful bastards want to go ahead and
subscriber the reject nation if you like
us I wanted to say thank you to RealD 3d
we went to an early advanced screening
of this movie so we got to watch this
Twice first time RealD 3d had a very
impressive 3d in the movie honestly it
was kind of a weird day for me that
night my mind was just not ready to
absorb the story and visuals
simultaneously there were people even
net and when I got to the elevator who
were like a little bit of difficulty
keeping up with the movie at the time
fortunately we got invited to go watch
it again second time on 4dx which was
not 3d before DX you know with the
Creed's
FEX yeah for an environment Dave and
hooked up these cool LEGO sets types of
things that are cgv cinema screen X
format that was also really cool and I'm
kind of a toss-up by which one I prefer
I feel like I probably prefer the 40 X
RealD 3d and 40 X or partner together so
they don't mind us saying that your
favorite kid you know sometimes I prefer
the 3ds sometimes / 40 X I'll tell you
this both formats are absolutely worth
watching in you're not just saying that
I'm like I kind of don't know how to
imagine not watching it in one of those
formats now oh yeah I mean the movie
itself is such a roller coaster that
they're gonna enhance it for ya and it's
cool that with if you get a 3d version
and the 40 X is not 3d so you do get two
very distinct versions thank you guys so
much for that anyway onto the actual
review part here we have the fortunate
opportunity of watching it twice and
honestly the first time I watch it I
really just didn't know how I felt about
it I knew a lot of people really liked
it and you were pretty surprised by it
yeah yeah definitely I mean it's
surpassed expectations that I didn't
necessarily have I guess because you
know I really loved the first lego movie
I was very surprised by the things that
that movie brought us and I didn't have
great expectations going into that one
either in a smaller way this time I kind
of got that same experience of like oh
this is a lot more than I thought it was
gonna be I'll meet you there because
it's a movie that's not just oh you know
much of humor and that's all it's there
for because that's kind of the
impression the trailer has left me with
yeah which was we're just gonna get a
bunch of jokes and and which is one of
the highlights of the lego movie
franchise as a whole is that they're
they're very funny movies they're very
energetic movies which is an element I
would never want to lose I just thought
that's all we're gonna get whereas like
the first lego movie was a surprisingly
nuanced story yeah that had a really
cool twist reveal at the end and this
movie greatly follows in that footstep
because spoilers if you haven't seen the
first lego movie really I don't think
you should watch this movie unless you
see that's the thing about this one's
like you really shouldn't watch this one
unless you've seen the first yeah it's
like The Incredibles - in the sense that
it just picks up directly at the end of
the night yeah
in the context of that ties in heavily
to the story yeah especially the twist
reveal at the end of the first lego
movie because at the end of the first
one you discover like oh there's this
whole thing with Will Ferrell being a
dad he's gonna business this is all in
the imagination of a kid sort of
figuring out their life through fantasy
and and that this one is chronicling the
story of the brother and sister now and
that's not a spoiler because unlike the
first movie where that's a reveal at the
end this movie I think starts off with
setting that up in the real world and
saying your sister now as opposed to the
first one which only has that in the end
sequence this checks in with the
real-life brother and sister throughout
the movie yeah this draws it a more
lucid parallel between the stakes and
the real world and the stakes and the
fantasies so it does yeah but in kind of
periodically throughout the movie I'm
gonna go in circle back to that in a
second because that's a big part that we
both have different notes on yeah which
greatly affected our viewing experiences
there's so I'm gonna circle back to that
in a second yeah there's a lot going on
in this movie and so III do think that
people coming out of it will have a lot
of different puzzle pieces to kind of
compare and contrast with each other
yeah cuz the rules of the way the
story's being told makes it a little
confusing now regardless of that like
and before we circle back to that I will
say that this movie is very much nuanced
like that's something they did not lose
which I'm so happy they didn't lose it's
more than just a a bunch of quirky
comedy which is also very present here
and is very there some really funny ass
moments in this movie the imagination is
nothing short of incredible again it's
easy to be kind of cynical now with so
much lego movie franchise stuff
happening to go I'm sick of the lego
movie franchise but then when you check
back in with especially with an
animation like this you go wow this is
like really freaking crazy it's like
with these two movies I feel like they
stand out from the Lego stuff because
like I liked Lego Batman did not see
Ninjago I heard that Ninjago was kind of
a sign that they need to kind of flip
their formula and like Oh Batman was a
movie I thought was you know fun
enjoyable but I didn't love it and so it
does really seem like the Lego movies
proper are kind of the flagship where
you're gonna get something that's both
fun
interesting hats off to Lord Miller I
guess because they seem to be the
crucial element that kind of makes these
movies what they are because you have
yeah all that mad cat humor all the
references all the bright colors and
imaginative textures and stuff like that
like that's one thing I really
appreciated about this is it's not just
the Legos anymore as you travel to you
know the sisters side of the story
even just the tangible things start to
change there's like all this chiffon
around and stuff yams for texture and
whatnot and I think they got really
imaginative just with the kind of
physical rules of their world more than
five minutes into this review if you
don't know the plot of the movie yeah
break it everything it's five years
after the events of the first one and
everything's like a post-apocalyptic
world now you know bleak like that's the
big Jim it's all bleak it's on the
trailer ready reboots yeah yeah there's
some type of alien that attacks our main
heroes and they kidnaps a few of them
and then Chris Pratt's Emmett sets out
on a solo adventure to try and rescue
them which involves going across the
galaxy and stuff basically he's got to
do all the hero stuff but without their
help this yeah and then along the way he
ends up partnering with a guy named Rex
danger vest who to me is the highlight
of this movie I loved his character in
here yeah he's a very big play not just
on Chris Pratt because it's voiced by
Chris Pratt and that's the whole point
that it's voiced by Chris Pratt because
there's a lot of references that are
directly linked to Chris Pratt's career
but it's also just a play on that action
movie like hero as well so oh yeah for
me personally is actually being one of
my all my favorite genres I really loved
his character a lot it's so funny that
he's on screen basically doing a John
Wayne circa Kurt Russell exactly you
pray hear the voice yeah which is kind
of funny because the guy who directed
this movie did sky high yeah what's
funnier is that Chris Pratt plays the
son of Kurt Russell I was watching I'm
like he's kind of doing that Kurt
Russell John Wayne yeah it pretty much
gives you what the first movie gave you
I kind of get annoyed when I read this
kind of thing in in reviews but I'm
gonna say it the surprise element of
because I was so dazzled by
first one and being like is I think a
lot of us walked in that movie going
this is such a stupid idea lego movie
and then you watch you're like what you
said now we're used to that you know so
there's less of that host breathtaking
you know so some of that impact is not
as strongly there and is discovery and I
do think if the first one's not as fresh
in your mind it can be a little bit more
challenging to keep up with I haven't
seen the first one since I watched it in
the theaters that opening weekend go
back to this there were especially
picking up like instead of like
re-establishing in a lot of ways they
they kind of like really speed set up a
lot of things you know because it's
intended for the people who really
remember the first one and then
immediately so there was a lot of just
like oh it's a lot to keep up with I
forgot about this energy yeah I do think
maybe perhaps that is one of the biggest
benefits of visiting the lego movie
again pretty close to when you see the
sequel is just the energy and the kind
of madcap rhythm that you need to have
your mind tuned to because this is the
kind of movie where you have stuff isn't
fresh in your mind you might snag on a
detail and start wondering about it you
will probably miss things while doing
that yeah cuz there's so much happening
there's lots of humor there are lots of
references but they're also story points
coming out there are scenes changing
these are kinetic movies and there's
also a lot more if I recall a lot more
musical numbers in this one as opposed
to the first one all remembers
everything is awesome in the first one I
feel like that's the main thing I don't
feel like the the original lego movie
tries as hard to be a music : this has
like four good musical numbers and and
you know variations on everything is
awesome as well as those musicals but
they're also very meta self-aware
musical numbers the whole point is for
them to be very on the nose or
intentionally catchy and it is catchy
you know like there are songs you're
listening to you I want to give away
that when you're hearing them you're
like that is gonna get stuck in my head
yeah that's the clue I'm gonna give you
there's a lot of that the thing they're
kind of tiered the experience for me
both times I watched it and this is
where really our only main difference
comes in to emotionally being affected
by the movie the fact that we're
constantly checking in
brother and sister throughout it's not
like we have like these long drawn-out
scenes with them throughout but it is
frequent in the movie where you do check
in with them so for myself I personally
kept getting pulled out and less
emotionally invested in the lego movie
journey because I was aware like oh this
is all just a metaphor for the brother
and sister who are the who it's their
story so I was less pulled into the
journey because I was so aware of the
ideas and trying to latch onto the
metaphors it's kind of happen both times
I watch it I don't know how many people
really have this sort of hampering
experience with it because it's kind of
conflicting for me because I the time
you get to the end of this movie and you
get this really heartfelt message it's a
different type of message as opposed to
the first one I found a very impactful
and in the second time I got a little
misty-eyed by the time you get to that
finale point the thing though is
throughout the journey I'm so I'm so
aware like this isn't real this is this
is just the kids of this is all a
metaphor a part of the kids imagination
that it would pull me out as opposed to
the first one where that's not revealed
till the end so I'm very emotionally
thrusted into the journey and I feel
like I'm in Emmett's shoes in that movie
I feel like I'm on his journey and also
this one's more spread out and it's in
samba land it's less you're just with
Emmett and you're going on his journey
because you have his journey so yeah
that's my one thing as my emotional
experience was hampered by that but you
feel differently well yeah that that's
interesting to me because I actually had
a very opposite response to that word as
I kind of felt like oh this is a great
way to unify everything all the shoes
are the same Emmett's journey and and
you know the interplay between like him
and Rex and stuff like that and themes
that that brings up are all themes that
these kids are having to deal with in
Austin Civ Lee they're real life they
kind of just helped each other out for
me personally to make the stakes feel
very lived in because it's you know it's
who these kids are becoming but as
imagined through the scope of how
they're playing together you know how
they're spending time another reason why
conflicted on it is because of the fact
if this movie were to do the same
structure of the first one and you get
to the reveal of the brother and sister
at the very end I'd be like oh it's just
the same beat as the first movie
yeah it's probably smarter to do it this
way yeah and I feel like you might give
one of two responses which is the way
you respond the way I respond I do think
that at least for me it also helped to
ramp up some of just the stakes and the
tension to not even just the emotional
resonance but there were times where you
know then you start thinking about oh
this is happening in this part of the
story then what must be happening on the
other side of the story I still really
like the movie a lot I don't prefer it
over the first one but I still think
it's a really worthwhile journey I think
it's a great movie theater experience
and it's some really funny wildly amount
of stuff and some like very memorable
musical numbers in there too oh yeah
definitely I mean this this movie I
don't know if I would say yeah that I
like it more than the first lego movie
but I do think it's a really well earned
sequel double down on making it still
you know kind of subversive and
emotionally resonant and all the stuff
that you want from the first one too so
yeah even though I'm not quite as jazzed
about it I still really appreciate what
they did here and I think it's
definitely well earned and well worth
the watch you know ain't meant to that
sister well guys what movie franchise or
thingy would you like to see converted
to the lego movie format comment below
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell and
also make sure that when you go watch
this movie watch it either in RealD 3d
because they have greatly upgraded their
3d format it's crazy and also or 40x
one of the two seriously recommend one
of those formats because I can't imagine
watching in any other way
thank you guys have a good day